[Música]
así se deja atún lleno de humo mientras
continúan los combates en la ciudad los
aviones militares y el fuego antiaéreo
volvieron a golpear la capital sudanesa
esto a pesar del alto el fuego previsto
hasta la medianoche del miércoles y que
ha sido violado en repetidas ocasiones
el número de víctimas varía los días que
hay combates en la zona recibimos entre
30 y 40 heridos las cifras varían según
la presidencia de Sudán del sur este
martes los líderes del ejército y de las
fuerzas paramilitares aprobaron un nuevo
de una semana el presidente Sur sudanés
Se involucró personalmente en la
mediación el general del fatal bruján y
el General Mohamed adamlo han acordado
en principio una tregua de 7 días del 4
al 11 de mayo también han acordado
nombrar a sus representantes para los
encuentros de paz que se celebrarán en
cualquier lugar de su elección ninguna
de las treguas anteriores ha sido
respetada y por el momento ninguno de
los dos líderes ha hecho comentarios
sobre el anuncio la nación de más de 45
millones de habitantes está sumida en el
caos desde que estallaron los combates
el 15 de abril los enfrentamientos han
dejado al menos 500 muertos y miles de
heridos principalmente en jartum y
darfurt según la ONU estas cifras
podrían ser en realidad mucho más
elevadas